So, I've bought, like, six Lululemon headbands over the past week. That's my new obsession, is buying fancy headbands, trying to find the ones that are most comfortable, and then, like, I need enough to, like, wear one all the time because my hair is kind of crazy. I could get a haircut. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 19, recorded on February 6, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we talk about getting started in tech. No, don't do it, man. I'm growing my hair out, too, to look like Bartosz Maluski in the hopes that looking more like him will give me an edge at understanding category theory. Some of my best memories are hanging out with him at C++ now and also watching my old mentor Hartmut uh hang out with him it's so Hartmut uh I think when we
过去这一周，我大概买了六个露露乐蒙（Lululemon）的发带。我现在的新爱好就是买各种时髦的发带，试图找到最舒服的那一款，而且我需要买足够多，这样就能一直戴着，因为我的头发实在太乱了。我本可以去剪个头发。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，这是第 19 期，录制于 2021 年 2 月 6 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 将聊聊如何进入科技行业。不，别入行，伙计。我也在留长发，想留成 Bartosz Maluski 那样，希望长得像他能让我在理解范畴论时更有优势。我最美好的回忆之一就是在 C++ Now 大会上和他待在一起，还有看着我的老导师 Hartmut 和他待在一起，Hartmut……我想当他……
when I was working for him back in you know 2010 to 2014 period I think Hartmut was in his 40s or 50s and like he he was not a he was not a young guy you, and he was not also, you know, a party animal. But I still remember one year at C++ Now where him and Eric Niebler stayed up literally all night. They pulled an all-nighter in the bar working on something. I think it might have been related to ranges. I think that was the year where there was somebody gave a talk that touched upon the idea of ranges and other languages and i remember being in the audience sitting next to eric and uh eric just watching the talk and he just says huh and uh then i don't know that these two events are related but shortly thereafter Eric started working on the ranges. That's just my recollection.
当我在 2010 年到 2014 年期间为他工作时，Hartmut 大概四五十岁，他已经不是个年轻人了，而且他也不是那种喜欢聚会的人。但我依然记得有一年在 C++ Now 大会上，他和 Eric Niebler 彻夜未眠。他们在酒吧里通宵工作，好像是在研究什么东西。我觉得可能和 ranges（范围库）有关。那一年好像有人做了一个演讲，涉及到了其他语言中 ranges 的概念。我记得当时坐在 Eric 旁边，听着那个演讲，Eric 只是说了句“嗯”，然后……我不知道这两件事是否有联系，但不久之后 Eric 就开始着手研究 ranges 了。这只是我的记忆。
I might be completely wrong but I have so many fond memories of the C++ nows of old. Yeah, I'm jealous I didn't join the inner community until later. Yeah, well. Never met Bartosz. At what age did you learn, did you start programming? I mean, so technically, when did I start programming? I mean, in first year of university, it was my first programming course.
我可能完全记错了，但我对过去那些 C++ Now 大会有很多美好的回忆。是啊，我很嫉妒自己加入这个核心社区比较晚。是啊，好吧。从来没见过 Bartosz。你是几岁开始学习编程的？我是说，严格来说，我什么时候开始编程的？大概是在大学一年级，那是我的第一门编程课。
But then I sort of had three courses where I did coding in, and then that was it. And so I sort of paused that for, what was it, 2012 to 2014 when I started my job. Or not, 2012 is a bit. the point is is I like I took courses on and off in university and then when I started my job at um ggy now known as moody's um then I started programming for work and technically like when we talked about ti basic you were telling me about all these games, like, the extent of my programming was the quadratic formula. And like a few other small, like math programs. And like if else statements, like I didn't do anything fancy. And honestly, like, I didn't even know I was programming.
但后来我大概只上了三门有编程内容的课程，然后就结束了。所以我在 2012 年到 2014 年我开始工作时暂停了编程。或者说，2012 年有点……重点是，我在大学里断断续续地上过课，后来我在 GGY（现在叫 Moody's）开始工作，那时我才为了工作开始编程。严格来说，当我们谈到 TI Basic 时，你跟我讲了那么多游戏，而我编程的极限就是求根公式。还有其他一些小的数学程序。还有 if-else 语句，我没做过什么花哨的东西。老实说，我甚至都不知道自己在编程。
When I was working on the TI basic. Yeah, I don't I don't think I was either. And, you know, when I was a kid, I was raised by a single mother who's an absolutely great person. But she is not a technology minded person. She was a lawyer by day, yoga instructor by night. I never had a computer in the house. I never had a gaming console in the house either because she was of the mind that if I had a game console, I would be spending all my time playing games on the TV instead of going outside and smelling the roses. But I didn't have a computer in the house until I was maybe like 11 or 12. I remember when I was in elementary school, I knew so much about PowerPoint and Excel and Word that the librarian had me assist him in putting together, I think, tutorials for either other students or for the teachers on how to use Office. But I didn't have a computer at home.
当我在用 TI Basic 的时候。是啊，我觉得我当时也不知道。你知道，我小时候是由单亲妈妈抚养长大的，她是个非常伟大的人。但她不是那种有科技头脑的人。她白天是律师，晚上是瑜伽教练。我家里从来没有电脑。家里也没有游戏机，因为她认为如果我有游戏机，我就会把所有时间都花在电视游戏上，而不是去户外闻闻花香。直到我大概 11 或 12 岁，家里才有了电脑。我记得上小学时，我对 PowerPoint、Excel 和 Word 的了解非常多，以至于图书管理员让我协助他为其他学生或老师制作 Office 使用教程。但我家里没有电脑。
The only computer I had access to was at school. And then even when I was in middle school, I didn't really have a computer. I think I got a computer at home when I was in middle school, but it was the same thing when I was in middle school where I just had the computer at school. And I don't know if I've told this story in this podcast, but I went to a very funky middle school. And I don't know if I've told this story in this podcast, but I went to a very funky middle school. It was called Talcott Mountain Academy. It's in Connecticut where I grew up. And it was this private school that was, it was a nonprofit. It was on top of this mountain. And the site had begun its life as a U.S. military base. It was a Nike missile site for, you know, like intercepting incoming Soviet bombers. And then I think in like the 70s or 80s, it got converted into a weather station and then it later turned into a
我唯一能接触到的电脑是在学校。即使上了初中，我也没有真正的电脑。我想我上初中时家里有了一台电脑，但情况和小学一样，我只是在学校用电脑。我不知道在这个播客里讲过这个故事没有，但我上了一所非常特别的初中。我不知道在这个播客里讲过这个故事没有，但我上了一所非常特别的初中。它叫 Talcott Mountain Academy，在我长大的康涅狄格州。那是一所私立学校，是非营利性的。它坐落在一座山顶上。那个地方最初是美国的一个军事基地。它曾是一个耐克导弹基地，你知道，就是用来拦截苏联轰炸机的。后来大概在 70 或 80 年代，它被改建成了一个气象站，之后又变成了一个……
science center and then they opened up a school and this school was like very very non-conventional biology class would involve this like six foot tall instructor Mr. Noonan who was like this big tough guy he would go and take all of the, middle schoolers out into the woods to go like catch snakes or something. And, uh, we had, there, there was, um, there was a weather station there. So once a week we had a class where, um, we would produce a, um, uh, a weather report, like a TV weather report, because there was a film studio at my middle school. And so all the kids, you know, each week you'd have a different role. Maybe you'd be the director or you'd be the talent who was, you know, on the air, or you'd be the camera operators. Like it would all be run by the kids and we'd make like a five minute weather broadcast.
科学中心，然后他们开办了一所学校。这所学校非常非常非传统。生物课会涉及到一个六英尺高、名叫 Noonan 先生的老师，他是个强壮的硬汉，他会带着所有初中生去树林里抓蛇之类的东西。而且，我们那里有一个气象站。所以每周我们有一节课，我们会制作一份天气预报，就像电视天气预报那样，因为我的初中里有一个电影工作室。所以所有的孩子，你知道，每周你都会扮演不同的角色。也许你是导演，或者是出镜的“人才”，或者是摄像师。这一切都由孩子们来运营，我们会制作一个五分钟的天气广播。
And we'd have like astronomy class because there were some pretty big telescopes, um, uh, at the, uh, school. The, one of the school's benefactors was, um, Alan being the fourth guy to walk on the moon. I know a lot of weird stuff about him because he was like the school's like benefactor and hero. But anyways, so to give you, I think this story gives you the best sense of the atmosphere and culture of the school. So it was maybe like 80 kids total from like kindergarten to like eighth grade. And they were very informal and sort of down to earth. And so the staff would often have their staff meeting in the morning, sort of like right in front of the kids, just like, you know, huddled.
我们还有天文学课，因为学校里有一些相当大的望远镜。学校的赞助人之一是 Alan Bean，第四个登上月球的人。我知道很多关于他的奇怪事情，因为他是学校的赞助人和英雄。但无论如何，我觉得这个故事最能体现学校的氛围和文化。全校从幼儿园到八年级总共大概只有 80 个孩子。他们非常随和，脚踏实地。所以教职员工经常在早上当着孩子们的面开会，就像那样，你知道，聚在一起。
And one morning the dean comes in and she's like, well, we need somebody to substitute for the, you know, the younger kids computer class today. And I like jokingly raised my hand. And I was a little bit of a troublemaker. And none of the teachers volunteer. So she looks around. She looks at me.
一天早上，院长走进来，她说，好吧，我们今天需要有人给低年级的计算机课代课。我开玩笑地举起了手。我当时有点调皮。没有老师自愿。所以她环顾四周。她看着我。
She shrugs and she's like, all right. And somehow I ended up teaching that class for the next like six months. Pretty much unsupervised. I'm pretty sure there was some supervision, but they were pretty much like, they gave me the freedom to sort of, you know, do what I wanted. And I showed the kids how to like the younger kids, how to use computers. And, uh, I don't remember what exactly the extent of my instruction was, but it like, this was the type of school where
她耸耸肩说，好吧。不知怎么的，接下来的六个月里，我竟然一直在教那门课。几乎没有人监督。我很确定还是有一些监督的，但他们基本上就是给了我自由，让我做我想做的事。我教孩子们，那些低年级的孩子，如何使用电脑。而且，我不记得我具体的教学内容是什么，但这所学校就是那种……
a student could just volunteer to teach a class and the teacher would just be like, yeah, okay. Seems, seems fine. But, uh, that's one of my earliest memories of doing stuff with computers. But the reason why I brought up this whole topic is, uh, I didn't have a computer in the house until I was, um, 11 or 12. And I didn't really start programming until I was in, you know, my first or second year of college. I think you and I basically started programming around the same time. But I meet a ton of people in tech who tell me that they started programming at a very young age. You know, they had a parent that was tech savvy. And it's like one of the things that I think you and I share is that we both were relatively late bloomers. You know, we didn't start programming at age, you know, 10 in, you know, C don't know if it's a bias, but I think there's actually a lot more people like that. I have the same impression of that as I do of startups.
学生可以自愿教课，老师只会说，好的，没问题。看起来，看起来挺好。但是，这是我最早关于使用电脑的记忆之一。但我提起这个话题的原因是，我直到 11 或 12 岁家里才有电脑。而且我直到大学一年级或二年级才真正开始编程。我想你和我基本上是在同一时间开始编程的。但我在科技行业遇到了很多人，他们告诉我他们很小的时候就开始编程了。你知道，他们的父母很懂技术。我觉得你和我有一个共同点，那就是我们都是相对“大器晚成”的人。你知道，我们没有在 10 岁时就开始用 C 语言编程。我不知道这是否是一种偏见，但我认为实际上有更多这样的人。我对这一点有和对初创公司一样的印象。
Like I read an article headline the other day that said average age of successful startup, 45. But most people's impression of startup founders are university dropouts that went on to found companies like Facebook. And even Bezos, I think, was in his late 20s. Maybe he was actually 30 when he did it. But there's a bunch of, like, young people that go on to, like, drop out of school and become super famous. But that is not the majority of people that are successful with startups. It's people with experience under their belts. And you hear about all these people that started coding at, you know, age seven on their, you know, Zed 80, whatever, some instruction thing that, you know, Jason Turner. For the Americans, that's Z80.
比如我前几天读到一篇新闻标题，说成功初创公司的平均年龄是 45 岁。但大多数人对初创公司创始人的印象是像 Facebook 那样辍学的大学生。即使是贝佐斯，我想他当时也快 30 岁了。也许他做的时候确实是 30 岁。但确实有一群年轻人辍学并变得非常出名。但这并不是大多数在初创公司取得成功的人。他们是那些经验丰富的人。你听说过所有那些在 7 岁时就在 Z80 上开始编程的人，不管是什么指令集，你知道，Jason Turner。对于美国人来说，那是 Z80。
And yeah, we we had a computer. I looked it up. it was a company called e-machines and i i remember distinctly it was around grade three or four which would have been like 2003 or four and i remember for our science fair projects like the first thing that we ever sort of did i did on them was like make graphs in Excel for our, our, uh, experiment part. Um, but yeah, we, we never really used it much for word processing. I, I also did not have like parents in tech. Um, my dad was a journalist, so technically he did work on a computer for a living, but mostly just, uh, writing. Um, but yeah, you met, you fell way steeper and faster into like C++ than I did. Mine was a lot more gradual. Like my career, I arguably wasn't even like a full software developer for the first four years of it. So yeah, and I got started when I was a kid, I played a lot of
是的，我们有一台电脑。我查了一下，是一家叫 e-machines 的公司。我清楚地记得那是在三年级或四年级左右，也就是 2003 或 2004 年。我记得我们的科学展览项目，我们做的第一件事就是在 Excel 中为我们的实验部分制作图表。但是，是的，我们从来没有真正用它来处理文档。我的父母也不是搞技术的。我爸爸是记者，所以严格来说他确实靠电脑谋生，但主要是写作。但是，是的，你比我更深入、更快地陷入了 C++ 的世界。我的过程要缓慢得多。比如我的职业生涯，前四年我甚至可以说不是一个全职软件开发人员。所以，是的，我小时候就开始了，我玩了很多……
text based games called MUDs, which is basically like a multiplayer game, but it's all text-based. There's no GUI. And I got started programming because I was interested in writing my own MUD or I was interested in running my own MUD. And somebody that I knew who ran a MUD told me,
基于文本的游戏，叫 MUD，基本上就是多人游戏，但全是基于文本的。没有图形界面。我开始编程是因为我想写一个自己的 MUD，或者我想运行一个自己的 MUD。我认识的一个运行 MUD 的人告诉我，
look, if you're going to run a MUD, you should like, it's fine to work with a coder, but you should be able to do all the coding yourself if you need to, because in a volunteer project, you can never really rely fully on others, he told me. So that's what inspired me to go learn to program. And I was working with this one guy and he suggested, hey, we should write this in C++. Most MUDs were written in a C code base,
听着，如果你要运行一个 MUD，你应该……和程序员合作没问题，但如果需要的话，你应该能够自己完成所有的编码，因为在志愿者项目中，你永远无法完全依赖他人，他告诉我。这就是激励我去学习编程的原因。我和一个人合作，他建议说，嘿，我们应该用 C++ 来写这个。大多数 MUD 都是用 C 代码库编写的，
but he wanted to do it in sort of what was at the time modern C++. This was before C++11. And when I was working on that project with him, he was using, I've mentioned before, the first piece of Boost I've ever been exposed to, which was Boost's algorithm for splitting up strings.
但他想用当时所谓的现代 C++ 来写。那是在 C++11 之前。当我和他一起做那个项目时，他正在使用我之前提到过的，我接触到的第一个 Boost 组件，也就是 Boost 的字符串分割算法。
And then I started started contributing to Boost. Within the first three or six months of getting started with programming in C++, I was contributing to Boost. And that's not an indication that I'm some brilliant, skilled programmer. I was just very fortunate that the, the Boost community was very accepting of a, you know, an eager, you know, like inexperienced programmer who wanted to make contributions. which I was like contributing a big open source projects was very rapid but the time from when I started programming to when I actually became you know an experienced programmer it took me a few years as it does everybody um uh but yeah you you sort of had a not a slower start but it was like more of a trickle for you. For me, it was just like, I just sort of started doing this thing and it quickly took over my whole life. Whereas you, you know, you started doing it for work and then you, it slowly became something where you got more and more involved with, you know, open source and the tech community. Yeah. Yeah, it was, I just ended up, I pursued a different field, ended up at a company where you were a domain expert using programming as your tool, and then fell in love with the software
然后我开始为 Boost 做贡献。在开始 C++ 编程的前三到六个月内，我就在为 Boost 做贡献了。这并不代表我是什么天才、技术高超的程序员。我只是非常幸运，Boost 社区非常接纳一个渴望学习、缺乏经验的程序员，他想要做出贡献。我为大型开源项目做贡献的速度非常快，但从我开始编程到真正成为一名有经验的程序员，我花了几年的时间，就像每个人一样。但是，是的，你的起步不算慢，但对你来说更像是一个缓慢的过程。对我来说，我只是开始做这件事，它很快就占据了我整个生活。而你，你知道，你是为了工作才开始做的，然后它慢慢变成了你越来越多地参与开源和技术社区的事情。是的。是的，我只是最终追求了不同的领域，进入了一家公司，在那里你是一名领域专家，把编程作为你的工具，然后爱上了软件开发这一面。
development side of things. And it's interesting because we sort of started talking just about random things, and now we're in the middle of our episode. So maybe we should turn this into a... I'm not sure what you think. I can cut this out if you think it's a bad idea, but advice for people that want to get into tech later because not super often, but a lot of times people... It's not so much about getting into tech yeah uh later because um not super often but a lot of times people not it's not so
这很有趣，因为我们一开始只是在聊一些随机的事情，现在我们已经聊到这一期节目的中间了。所以也许我们应该把它变成一个……我不确定你怎么想。如果你觉得这是个坏主意，我可以剪掉，但给那些想晚点进入科技行业的人一些建议，因为虽然不是特别频繁，但很多时候人们……这与其说是关于进入科技行业，
much about getting into tech it's like you know i want to become an awesome c++ programmer you know where do i start or yada yada yada and i like i always feel weird answering the question because like i don't i don't think there's any one path and i don't really think i'm a good person to ask um but i don't know if you have thoughts good person to ask. But I don't know, if you have thoughts, you can share them. And like, yeah, we both started late. Yep. We're both in tech. So I'm sure there's a lot of people in that position right now. You know, what should. So I think that if you're looking to get into tech in particular, if you're looking to get into any sort of role where you're going to do, you know, programming or software design, I think the first thing that you want to figure out,
不如说是关于……你知道，我想成为一名出色的 C++ 程序员，我该从哪里开始，诸如此类。我回答这个问题时总是感到很奇怪，因为我不认为有什么唯一的路径，我也不认为我是个合适的人选。但我不知道你有什么想法，如果你有想法，可以分享一下。是的，我们都是晚起步的。是的。我们都在科技行业。所以我相信现在有很多处于那个位置的人。你知道，应该……所以我认为，如果你想进入科技行业，特别是如果你想进入任何需要进行编程或软件设计的岗位，我认为你想弄清楚的第一件事，
or I'm not going to say the first thing because it's actually hard to figure this out, but the most important thing for you to figure out long-term is what you actually want to be doing. And I'll explain what I mean by that. There are a lot of different roles that one can play in the world of software. I think like most fundamentally, it splits down into two basic categories. There are folks that are really interested and passionate in developing software itself. You know, sort of regardless of the application, what your interest is is in developing the software, writing the code, etc. And then the other sort of broad category is what you started out doing, Connor, which
或者我不会说是第一件事，因为这实际上很难弄清楚，但从长远来看，对你来说最重要的事情是弄清楚你到底想做什么。我会解释我的意思。在软件世界中，一个人可以扮演很多不同的角色。我认为最根本的是，它分为两个基本类别。一类人对开发软件本身非常感兴趣和充满热情。你知道，不管应用是什么，你的兴趣在于开发软件、编写代码等。而另一个大类就是你最初做的事情，Connor，
is you want to use programming or software development for some particular goal. I work a lot in HPC and we often talk about the distinction between somebody that is a software engineer or a programmer versus a computational scientist that for like a programmer or software engineer, the primary focus is the code themselves. That's what you're interested in. That's what you want to be doing. Whereas if you're a computational scientist or somebody that, you know, is a domain expert who's in some field and you're just using programming as a tool, the programming isn't the primary thing that you're doing. You're using it as a tool to advance some other things, you know,
你想为了某个特定的目标而使用编程或软件开发。我在高性能计算（HPC）领域工作很多，我们经常讨论软件工程师或程序员与计算科学家之间的区别。对于程序员或软件工程师来说，主要焦点是代码本身。那是你感兴趣的，那是你想做的。而如果你是一名计算科学家，或者是一个在某个领域有专长的领域专家，你只是把编程作为一种工具，那么编程并不是你所做的主要事情。你把它作为一种工具来推进其他事情，你知道，
to build some application that you really care about, to do some science that you think is really important. And I think it's really critical for people who want to get into the field to decide where they fall here. Are you just really passionate about software development in general? Or is your passion in what you can use software to do? Yeah. Well, so say someone has identified that, and I should say, too, that I think, well, actually, I'm not sure if I think or if it's this is a widely acknowledged fact, but I think the number of individuals that fall into that latter category that are insert,
构建你真正关心的应用程序，做一些你认为非常重要的科学研究。我认为对于想进入这个领域的人来说，决定他们属于哪一类是非常关键的。你是对一般的软件开发充满热情吗？还是你的热情在于你能用软件做什么？是的。好吧，假设有人确定了这一点，我也应该说，其实我不确定这是否是我的想法，或者这是否是一个被广泛认可的事实，但我认为那些属于后一类的人，也就是被称为计算科学家的人，数量……比如一个例子，当我在亚马逊面试时，我也在面试多伦多的一家咨询公司。他们非常想聘请我，因为我有作为领域专家的经验，但我是一个对软件开发方面更感兴趣的人，并且引入了最佳实践之类的东西，因为他们有一个从事航空业的客户，他们基本上有一个巨大的遗留代码系统，是由那些航空专家编写的，他们也有完全相同的代码库，他们不是软件开发人员，也没有使用最佳实践，但他们有兴趣引入那些能够引入这些东西的人。所以我认为在很多行业中，都有代码库存在，
you know, title computational scientists. Like one example, while I was interviewing for Amazon, I was also interviewing for a consulting company in Toronto. And they were really interested in bringing me on because of my experience, like working as a domain expert, but someone who was more interested in the software development side and like introducing best practices and stuff like that because they had a client that was working in aviation and they basically had like a huge legacy code system of like people that were aviation experts that also had the exact same kind of code base like they were not software developers and didn't use best practice stuff but they were interested in bringing on people that were able to introduce that stuff. And so I think in so many industries, there are code bases out there that
只是专家们在使用编程和软件作为工具。但无论如何，假设你已经做出了那个决定，接下来该怎么办？我假设大多数问这个问题的人，他们对想要进入的行业其实没那么具体，我感觉有很多人联系我，他们大多是……他们不想直接说出来，但就像是“我想要一份科技行业的六位数工作”，他们并没有真正问自己“我想做什么”，他们只是想进入科技行业，在那之后，在他们获得了一点经验之后，他们才会开始决定他们真正想在职业生涯中追求什么。
are just experts using programming and software as a tool. But anyway, say you've made that decision, like what next? I assume most of the people that are asking it, they actually are less specific about like an industry that they want to go into and they just like i feel like there's a lot of folks that reach out and they're just mostly like they don't want to outright say it but it's like i want a six-figure job in tech um and they don't really ask themselves like what do they want to do um they just they want to be in tech and after after that point, after they've gotten a little bit of experience, then they'll maybe start to decide where do they really want to
他们只是想在一家薪水不错的公司里找到立足之地。嗯，而且我认为，在你进入科技行业时，你几乎不可能弄清楚你到底想做什么。而且这也是会改变的。比如，在我回答你的问题之前，我先给你举个例子。你知道，当我开始我的职业生涯时，我以为我永远会是一名个人贡献者，一个多产的程序员，我对管理或领导力并不真正感兴趣。我只想写代码，我做了几年。当时我在做高性能计算，有一段时间我正在从事高性能计算应用程序，
take their career. They just sort of, they just want to get their foot in the door at a company with a good salary. Well, and, and I think, I think it's almost impossible for you to figure out what exactly you want to be doing. Like as you're entering a career in tech. And it's also something that's going to change. Like, I'll just give you an example before I actually answer your question. You know, when I was, when I started my career, I thought I was always going to be, you know, an individual contributor, you know, this prolific programmer, and I was not really interested in management or leadership. I just wanted to write code, and I did that for a few years. And I was working in HPC at the time, and there was a period where I was working on HPC applications
那时我以为我的兴趣可能会变成成为一名计算科学家。我当时正在做一些非常酷的气候和天体物理模拟。我觉得我适合做那个，因为我擅长理解物理学家和气候科学家想要什么，同时也擅长与我共事的科学家和纯软件人员进行沟通。
and where I thought that maybe my interest was going to be in becoming a computational scientist. I was working on some really cool climate in astrophysics simulations. And I thought I was good for that because I was good at understanding both what the physicists and climate scientists wanted and also understanding the, you know, I was good at communicating with both the scientists and the pure software folks
而且我也曾以为我整个职业生涯都会在学术界，直到我决定离开去公共部门或私营部门。现在我想我会永远留在私营部门，但这可能会改变。所以我认为这总是在不断演变的。我确实认为尽早弄清楚这一点对你有好处，因为它有助于指导你的优先级，以及你想加入的社区和你想要学习的技术。嗯，我认为每个人的学习风格都不同。嗯，至少对我来说，当我开始时，我做的是找了一位导师。而且，那位导师真的塑造了我，真的把我塑造成了一名软件工程师。对我来说，找一位导师
that I was working with. And I also sort of thought that I was going to be in academia my entire career until I decided to go leave for the public sector, or the private sector. And now I think I'll be in the private sector forever, but that might change. So I think it's always something that's evolving. I do think it's good for you to try to figure this out as early as you can, because it sort of helps you guide what your priorities should be and also what communities you want to become a part of and what technologies you want technologies you want to learn. Um, I think everybody has a different, um, uh, learning style. Um, for me, at least when I got started, um, what I did was I found a mentor. Um, and, uh, that mentor really shaped my, really has really shaped me as a software engineer. And for me, finding a mentor
意味着，当我年轻的时候，我以为自己是个相当聪明、相当精明的人。所以我总是告诉自己，我在寻找的导师是一个我真心认为比我聪明的人。就像，你知道，我可能有点傲慢。所以我想要找一个我打心底里认为比我聪明，我可以向他学习的人。拥有导师是非常宝贵的。你不仅能从他们那里学到技能，还能学到很多关于职业轨迹的知识。他们会帮助你建立你所需要的网络。我确实认为，如果你在科技行业，拥有一个专业网络是你所能拥有的最有价值的东西之一，因为它给了你很大的流动性。
meant I, when I was younger, I thought I was pretty, pretty smart and pretty slick guy. So I would always tell myself what I'm looking for in a mentor is somebody that I legitimately believe is smarter than me. Like, you know, I'm maybe a little bit of an arrogant guy. And so I want to find somebody that like I in my heart of heart, I really think this person's smarter than me and I can learn from this person. And having a mentor is just so valuable. You're not just going to learn the skills from them, but you're also going to learn a lot about, you know, career trajectories. And they're going to help you build the sort of network that you need. And I do think that having a professional network is one of the most valuable things that you can have if you're in tech because it gives you a lot of mobility.
所以尝试建立那个网络非常重要。但至少对我来说，我给人们的建议是尝试寻找一位导师。如果你是科技行业的新手，这通常很难做到。但当我刚进入科技行业时，我获得导师的方法是开始为 Boost 项目做贡献。你知道，我来了，我说，嘿，我有兴趣修复这个 bug。起初我只是提交 bug，但后来就开始修复它们了。随着我在社区中花费的时间越来越多，我认识了很多人。然后我和我共事的几个人变得亲近了，其中一个人成了我的导师，并给了我第一份工作。所以我认为找到一个
And so trying to build out that network is really important. But for me at least, my advice to people is to try to seek out a mentor. And that can often be hard to do if you're new to tech. But when I was new to tech, the way that I got a mentor was I started contributing to the Boost project. You know, I came, I said, hey, I'm interested in, you know, fixing this bug. I was just filing bugs at first, but then it was fixing them. And as I spent more time in the community, I got to know people. And then I got, you know, close with a couple of particular people that I was working with, and then one of them became my mentor and gave me my first job. And so I think finding a project
你有兴趣贡献的项目，即使你觉得你没有资格这样做，那也是一个很好的起步方式。我知道并不是每个人都是从开源开始的，但我真的只能谈谈我的经验，也就是，我确实是从为开源项目做贡献开始的。那确实引导我找到了我的第一份工作，当时我还是个大学辍学生。这不会适用于每个人，你知道。但至少对我来说，那是我的成功之路。那么 Bryce 的“科技行业成功之道”里有第一、第二和第三步吗？而且，你知道，第三步是找一位导师。第一步是找到一个你有兴趣贡献的开源项目？因为问题是，我肯定有很多听众在想，好吧，你说得太容易了，就像去找到一个开源项目，开始认识人，然后，你知道，从第二步到第三步，哦，然后你就有了导师。但我感觉很多时候，那些在做开源等等的人，可能没有好的机会或好的个人可以提供指导，或者，所以有没有更具体的，或者说，归根结底，这是否是非常……不是含糊其辞，但就像，这对每个人来说都是不同的，你只需要找到你感兴趣的东西并追求它，好事就会发生。我认为在你处于可以开始……你知道，你开始
that you're interested in contributing to, even if you feel like you're not qualified to do that, that can be a really good way to get started. I know not everybody gets started in open source, but I can really only speak to my experience, which is, you know, I did get started, you know, contributing to an open source project. And that did, you know, lead me to my first job when I was a college dropout. That's not going to be the case for everybody, you know. But at least for me, that was my path to success. So is there like a step one, two, and three in there of Bryce's how to make it in tech? And, and, you know, step three is getting a mentor. Step one is what finding an open source project
为一个项目做贡献的原因之一是你想要与科技社区建立联系，你想要开始建立一个专业网络。但你是对的，那有点像第二步或第三步。我认为在你做那件事之前，你必须弄清楚你的学习过程将是什么。对我来说，我不是一个在课堂环境中学习得很好的人。大学辍学过一次，后来我才拿到了学位。但大学对我来说从来都不是一段有趣的经历。我从来不喜欢大学。我从来没有真正觉得我在课堂上学到了什么。它总是感觉像是在做无用功。我总是开玩笑说，我学到东西的最后一个地方是我描述的那所奇怪的初中，顺便说一句，那是一所很棒的学校。如果你住在康涅狄格州，你想把孩子送到 Talcott Mountain Academy 这样伟大的学习机构。但对我来说，我学习的方式，我有点……我喜欢自学，我
that you're interested in contributing to? Because the thing is thing is is like i'm sure there's a lot of people listening and thinking well you're it's it's made it sounds so easy like just go and find an open source project start to get to know people and then you know from step two to three like oh then you've got a mentor but i feel like a lot of times people that are working on open source etc et cetera, like they, there may not be a good opportunity or good individual there for mentorship or like, so is there like more concrete or is it, is, is at the end of the day, is this, it's very sort of, um, not hand wavy, but just like, it's, it's going to be different for every single person and you just have to find what you're interested in and pursue it and good things will happen. I think before you're in a place where you can start, you know, one of the reasons why you start
不会去读一本关于编程的书。除了《编程要素》（Elements of Programming），我从来没有真正读过关于编程的书。我倾向于通过实践和例子来学习。所以，你知道，我不会去通读整个教程。我会从教程中找一些例子，然后就开始摆弄它。嗯，当我年轻的时候，我妈妈经常讲这个故事，关于我六岁时如何描述我学习的过程，我如何成为 PowerPoint 专家的。我告诉妈妈，好吧，我只是按了每一个按钮，看看它们都做了什么。嗯，这就是我学习的方式。嗯，所以我知道，如果我需要去学习一个新东西，我学习的方法就是
contributing to a project is that you want to get connected with a tech community and you want to start building a, you know, a professional network. But you're right, that is sort of like step two or three. I think before you do that, you have to figure out what your learning process is going to be. For me, I am not somebody who learns well in a classroom setting. Dropped out of college once, and then I subsequently got a degree. But college was never a fun experience for me. I never enjoyed college. I never really felt like I learned anything in the classroom. It always felt like make work. And I always joke the last place where I ever learned anything was that weird middle school that I described, which is a great school, by the way. If you live in Connecticut, you want to send your kids to a great learning institute at Talcott Mountain Academy. But so for me, the way that I learn, I sort of, I like to teach myself and I
去找一些我可以作为起点的例子，然后我就通过实践自学。但这不会对每个人都一样。但一旦我发现那是我的学习过程，我不是那种在课堂上学习的人，我通过自学、通过例子和通过实践学习得最好，那么我就知道我将如何建立我的技能组合，这与我拥有的任何导师或其他任何东西无关。现在，对于其他人来说，情况可能不同。你可能是一个通过书本学习的人。那么也许你想做的第一件事就是给自己找一些非常好的编程书籍。
don't go and like read a book about programming. I've never really read a book about programming except for elements of programming. I tend to like to learn by doing and to learn by example. So, you know, I'm not going to go and read through a tutorial in its entirety. I'm going to go and like get some example from the, you know, the tutorial and just start messing around with it. Um, when I was younger, my, my mom used to tell this story about how I, once I described to somebody how I learned as like a six-year-old, how I became a PowerPoint expert. And I told my mom, well, I just pressed every button to see what they all did. Um, so that's the way that I learned. Um, and so I know that like, if I need to go and learn a new thing, the way I'm going to do it is I'm
或者你可能是一个确实想在课堂上学习的人，在这种情况下，你知道，你必须看看，什么对你来说是最好的选择？你想在大学环境中学习吗？你想在代码训练营（code boot camp）那样的环境中学习吗？但弄清楚你将如何获得技能，这对每个人来说都是不同的，我认为这是你独立于任何其他事情的第一步。你不需要成为
going to go and find some example I can use as a starting point and then I'll just sort of teach myself by doing but that's it's not going to be the same for everybody but once I discovered that that was my learning process that I was not somebody that was going to learn in a classroom that I was going to learn best teaching myself and by example and through doing, then I knew how I was going to build up my skill set sort of independent of whatever mentor I had or whatever else. Now, for other people, it might be different. You might be somebody that, you know, you're going to learn from a book. And so then maybe the first thing you want to do is find yourself some really good programming books.
一名专家才能开始建立你的社区联系、专业网络等。但我确实认为你需要有一个独立于你的社区联系、网络等的学习过程。比如你不应该走出去尝试寻找导师，并期望导师会承担教育你的责任。你需要自己承担责任。这不是导师的目的。导师的目的是提供指导和见解，
Or you might be somebody that does want to learn in a classroom, in which case, you know, you got to look at, well, what's the best option for you? Do you want to do it in a college type environment? Do you want to do it at, you know, sort of like a code camp, code boot camp sort of environment? Do you want to do it at sort of like a code boot camp sort of environment? But figuring out how you're going to acquire your skills and it's going to be different for everybody, I think that's really your first step independent of anything else. You don't need to be
并帮助你建立联系。是的，我认为其中有一条非常棒的建议。并不是说其他的建议不棒，但特别地，你说你不需要成为专家就可以开始。在我的职业生涯或生活中，我有很多次对自己说，哦，我要写一个程序来做那个，但我还不知道怎么做，所以我要等到我在学校上课，教我制作那个程序的技能，然后我再在那个时候制作它。特别是我一直想做的一件事是编写一个技术股票筛选程序。在成为精算师之前，我曾经想成为一名宽客（quant）。宽客是定量分析师（quantitative analyst）的缩写。
an expert to start building out your community connections, your professional network, etc. But I do think you need to have a learning process that is independent of your community connections, your networking, et cetera. Like you shouldn't go out there and try to find a mentor and expect that a mentor is going to take on responsibility for educating you. You need to take responsibility for doing that yourself. That's not the purpose of a mentor. The purpose of a mentor is to provide guidance and insight
他们通常在华尔街工作，赚很多钱，只是为了处理数字。通常你必须去读硕士或博士。所以我花了很多时间看雅虎财经、谷歌财经，我从来没有对那些小的筛选选项感到满意。雅虎财经是唯一一个在 OHLC 图表中将成交量柱涂成相同颜色的网站。比如红色代表下跌日，绿色代表上涨日。底部通常有成交量，显示交易了多少股票。但雅虎是唯一一个
and to help you make connections. Yeah, I think there's a like a fantastic piece of advice in there. Not that all of it wasn't fantastic, but specifically, you said you don't need to be an expert to get started. And I so many times in my career or life have sort of thought to myself oh like I'm gonna write a program to do that but I just I don't know how to yet so like I'm gonna wait until I take the course in school that teaches me the skills to to make that program and then and then I'll make it at that point and like specifically one of the things I always wanted to do was write a, um, a technical stock screening program. I used to want to be a quant before I became an actuary. A quant is short for quantitative analyst or quantitative something.
把它们涂成相同颜色的网站。或者也许我记混了。无论如何，我以为我需要去上图形编程课。我需要更多的知识才能从互联网上抓取数据。长话短说，当我在中国时，我基本上已经停止去
And they work typically on wall street and get paid a lot of money just to crunch numbers. Typically you have to go get a master's or a PhD. So I had spent a lot of time looking at like, you know, Yahoo Finance, Google Finance, and I was never satisfied with like the little, you know, screening options. Yahoo Finance was the only website that would color their volume bars the same color in an OHLC chart. So like red is for a down day, green is for an up day. And like there's usually volume at the bottom, which shows how many shares of a stock traded. But Yahoo was the only website
上课了，你不能每天跳 12 小时的舞同时学习萨尔萨舞，所以我在不学跳舞的时候有很多空闲时间，所以我只是开始……我当时想，好吧，这能有多难？所以如果你在想，哦，我想做这个，我只是没有技能，好吧，你缺什么？这听起来很轻率，但只是……只是去谷歌搜索一下。如果有人说，我给你 1000 万美元，如果下个月你能构建出做这个的东西，而你不知道怎么做，显然你会尝试一下。你会怎么做？你的第一步可能是去谷歌搜索，比如如何构建 X 或如何做 X。你会惊讶于你能走多远。
that like colored it the same color. Or maybe I'm getting that mixed up. Anyways, I thought I needed to go take like a graphics programming course. And I needed a bunch of more knowledge in order to scrape data from the internet. And long story short, when I was in China and I had sort of stopped going to
很多时候你会碰壁。但是的，这和我现在的导师之一 Mason 博士很像。他说，他当时说，哦，你可以直接开始工作。我当时说，不，不，我得先做些研究。他说，不，不，不，不。你知道，先让它工作，然后让它变快，然后再做其他事情。但他的观点是，不要告诉自己你做不到某事，你需要去研究更多。直接开始做。
class you can't dance for like 12 hours a day while learning salsa so i had quite a bit of free time while i wasn't learning how to dance and so i just start i was just like well you know how hard could it be and so like if you're thinking to yourself oh i want to do this i just don't have the skill set like well what don't you have just, this sounds very flippant, but just, just like Google it. Like if someone said, I'll give you $10 million, if in the next month you can build, you know, something to do this, like, and you didn't know how, like, obviously you would give it a shot. Like, what would you do? Like your first step would probably to be like, to Google, like how to, how to build X or how to do X. And you'll be surprised like how far you can get.
你会惊讶于很多时候你能走多远。他们要么低估了自己，要么高估了做某事所需的资格。科技行业的一个常见问题，特别是对于来自代表性不足群体的人来说，是一个常见问题，就是人们因为不符合招聘启事上写的资格而不去申请工作。哦，你知道，我没有硕士学位。我不应该申请这份工作。或者，哦，我没有五年经验，所以我不应该申请这份工作，因为我没有满足所有条件。你知道，这总是一段旅程。拥有学位或证书本身并没有价值。真正重要的是你获得的技能。即使没有很多经验，即使作为初学者，你仍然可以做很酷、很棒的事情。有一个现象，我经常告诉 C++ 委员会的新成员，讲这样一个故事。有时，你知道，你在一个房间里，对某事有疑问。
A lot of the times you're going to end up banging your head against the wall. But yeah, it's very similar to one of my current mentors, Dr. Mason. He said, he was saying, oh, you can just go and start work on it. And I was like, no, no, I got to do some more research first. And he was like, no, no, no, no. You know, first make it work, then make it fast and then do something else. But his point was like don't tell yourself you can't do something and you need to go research more. Just start doing it.
很多时候，你最终会碰壁。不过，这和我现在的导师梅森博士的情况非常相似。他说，他当时说，哦，你可以直接开始做。我说，不，不，我得先做些研究。他说，不，不，不，不。你知道，先让它能运行，再让它变快，然后再做别的。但他的意思是，不要告诉自己你做不到，也不要觉得你需要去研究更多。直接开始做就行了。
And you'll be surprised a lot of the times, like how far you can get. they either underestimate themselves or they overestimate what qualifications they need to do a certain thing. Like what one common problem in tech, this is a particular problem for people from underrepresented groups, is people not applying for a job posting because they don't meet the qualifications that are written on the rec. The, oh, you know, I don't have a master's degree. I shouldn't apply for this job. Or, oh, I don't have five years of experience, so I shouldn't apply for this job because I don't check all the boxes. You know, it's always a journey. And having a degree or having a certificate, that in and of itself doesn't hold value. It's really about the skills that you acquire. And you can still do cool and great things even without a lot of experience, even as a beginner. There's a phenomenon that I often tell new members to the C++ committee, a story like this. Sometimes, you know, you're in a room and you have a question about something.
你会惊讶地发现，很多时候你能走多远。人们要么低估了自己，要么高估了做某事所需的资格。科技行业中一个常见的问题，特别是对于来自代表性不足群体的人来说，就是因为不符合招聘启事上写的资格要求而不去申请职位。比如，哦，你知道，我没有硕士学位，我不应该申请这份工作。或者，哦，我没有五年经验，我不应该申请这份工作，因为我没有满足所有条件。你知道，这总是一个过程。拥有学位或证书本身并没有价值。真正重要的是你获得的技能。即使没有丰富的经验，即使是初学者，你仍然可以做出很棒的事情。我经常给C++委员会的新成员讲一个现象，一个这样的故事。有时候，你知道，你在一个房间里，对某件事有疑问。
You know, you see something that you think might be a problem or you don't understand. and you have a question about something. You see something that you think might be a problem or you don't understand, and nobody else is asking that question. Everybody else is just sitting there nodding their heads, and you think, well, I'm not going to ask this because it might be embarrassing or it might be a dumb question. Everybody might know the answer, and so you don't ask the question. But sometimes that's the only room that there is. Like sometimes that room that you're in, that's the last room where there will be an opportunity to have that discussion. And yeah, sometimes that question or that comment that you have, you know, won't be, you know, brilliant and insightful. Sometimes
你知道，当你看到一些你认为可能有问题或者你不理解的事情，并且你对某事有疑问时。你看到一些你认为可能有问题或者你不理解的事情，而其他人都没有提出这个问题。其他人只是坐在那里点头，而你心想，好吧，我不打算问这个问题，因为它可能会让人尴尬，或者可能是一个愚蠢的问题。每个人可能都知道答案，所以你就不问了。但有时那正是唯一的空间。就像有时你所在的那个房间，那是最后一次有机会进行那种讨论的房间。是的，有时你提出的那个问题或评论，你知道，不会是那种非常出色和深刻的。有时
it'll have a simple answer. Sometimes you just will have misunderstood stuff. But sometimes, sometimes that insight that you had will be critical. And if you don't say it, there's not another room where somebody else is going to think of it and say it. Like in particular, I tell people on the C++ committee this. Like if you're in a room where we're reviewing a proposal that's going to go into the C++ standard and you have some question and you think, oh, this is a dumb question, I shouldn't ask it. Guess what? If everybody else in the room has that same question but they're thinking that,
它会有一个简单的答案。有时你只是误解了某些东西。但有时，有时你拥有的那种洞察力将是至关重要的。如果你不说出来，就没有另一个房间可以让别人想到并说出来。比如，我特别告诉C++委员会的人这一点。比如，如果你在一个房间里，我们正在审查一个即将进入C++标准的提案，而你有一些疑问，你心想，哦，这是一个愚蠢的问题，我不应该问。你猜怎么着？如果房间里的其他人也有同样的问题，但他们也在想，
that question will never get asked. And this principle can be applied to bug reports or code contributions too. Maybe you think, oh, well, maybe this is a bug in this API in this really popular library, but I'm just this new programmer. There's no way that I could have found some bug that these brilliant developers that made this really popular library wouldn't have found. I'm sure that it's just meant to work this way. Don't assume that. Don't assume that. Don't assume that just because you're inexperienced, that you can't have a meaningful impact. And you also, you shouldn't be afraid to ask questions or to ask for help or to say, I don't understand this. The further along I get in my career and the more and more responsibility that I take on, the more I find myself willing to say, I don't understand what you just said,
那个问题就永远不会被提出来。这个原则也可以应用于错误报告或代码贡献。也许你会想，哦，好吧，也许这是这个非常流行的库中的API的一个错误，但我只是一个新程序员。我不可能发现这些制造了这个非常流行的库的杰出开发者没有发现的错误。我相信它本来就是这样工作的。不要那样假设。不要那样假设。不要仅仅因为你缺乏经验，就认为你不能产生有意义的影响。而且你也不应该害怕提问或寻求帮助，或者说，我不明白这一点。我在职业生涯中走得越远，承担的责任越多，我就越发现自己愿意说，我不明白你刚才说了什么，
or explain it to me differently. Or the more frequent thing these days is I'll tell somebody, I don't understand what you're saying and I do not think I will understand it until you show me an example. Because for me, that's how I learn. And, you know, I know sometimes that there are other people in the room who probably understand exactly what's going on. But, like, I don't care if I look stupid. My only priority is for me to understand. So I'll stop and say, hey, I don't get this.
或者用不同的方式向我解释。或者这些天更常见的情况是，我会告诉某人，我不明白你在说什么，而且我认为除非你给我举个例子，否则我不会明白。因为对我来说，这就是我的学习方式。而且，你知道，我知道有时房间里有其他人可能完全理解正在发生的事情。但是，我不在乎我看起来是否愚蠢。我唯一的优先事项是我要理解。所以我会在那里停下来，说，嘿，我不明白这个。
Like, maybe the rest of you get this, but please help me. Yeah, there's two things I want to say. I was like, and 1000% agree with what you're saying. The first is a quote. The second is about Chris Lattner. I'm not sure if I made this quote up.
比如，也许你们其他人明白了，但请帮帮我。是的，有两件事我想说。我当时想，百分之一千同意你所说的。第一件事是一个引语。第二件事是关于Chris Lattner的。我不确定这个引语是不是我编的。
I must have stolen it from someone. But there's a bunch of these quotes of the difference between a junior and a senior software engineer is, and then insert some, you know, anecdote. And one of them is that a senior engineer is willing to ask the stupid questions. And like when I first heard this, or maybe, like I said, maybe I came up with it, like it resonated so deeply with me because for the first four years of my career, when I started, we worked on this immensely complicated code base, you know, millions of C++, millions of lines of C++, 30 years old, used to be written in, I think it was basic, and then they ported it. So like
我一定是偷来的。但有很多关于初级和高级软件工程师之间区别的引语，然后插入一些，你知道，轶事。其中之一是高级工程师愿意问愚蠢的问题。就像我第一次听到这个，或者像我说的，也许是我自己想出来的，它深深地引起了我的共鸣，因为在我职业生涯的前四年，当我刚开始时，我们在一个极其复杂的代码库上工作，你知道，数百万行C++，30年历史，过去是用，我想是Basic写的，然后他们移植了它。所以就像
some parts of the code base you'd run into that never get touched, looked really weird. And for like the first two years, I just didn't ask questions in meetings because I just always thought that like it's so complicated. There's like there's no way that like, you know, I'm like there's no way everyone in the room is confused. It's just that I don't know enough yet and I need to be silent and like put my time in. And then towards the end of my my career at that company or stay at that company, like I was asking so many questions because I realized like everyone was confused. Everyone in the meeting except for like two or three people that were the ones working on the current feature were confused about what was going on because it was just so complicated. And there's a fear of, like you said, looking
代码库中有些部分你永远不会碰到，看起来非常奇怪。在大约前两年，我在会议上根本不问问题，因为我总是认为它太复杂了。不可能，你知道，我不相信房间里的每个人都感到困惑。只是我还知道得不够多，我需要保持沉默，投入我的时间。然后在我那家公司职业生涯的末期，或者说在那家公司待了一段时间后，我问了很多问题，因为我意识到每个人都很困惑。会议中除了两三个正在开发当前功能的人之外，每个人都对正在发生的事情感到困惑，因为它太复杂了。而且有一种恐惧，就像你说的，看起来
stupid by asking a question. And you ultimately just need to get over that fear and start asking. I think I was talking about this with Guy Davidson. So maybe once again, I'm quoting Guy from this, the difference between junior and senior software engineers. But yeah, the second anecdote is that Chris Lattner, you know, famous for LLVM and Swift and a bunch of other projects mlir um if you've listened to him speak in talks or podcasts he says one of the things that he's perennially trying to do is make himself uncomfortable he wants to be the person in the room that like knows the least
通过问问题显得愚蠢。你最终只需要克服那种恐惧并开始提问。我想我是在和Guy Davidson谈论这件事。所以也许再一次，我是在引用Guy的话，关于初级和高级软件工程师的区别。但是是的，第二个轶事是Chris Lattner，你知道，以LLVM和Swift以及其他许多项目MLIR而闻名，如果你听过他的演讲或播客，他说他一直在尝试做的一件事就是让自己感到不舒服，他想成为房间里那个知道得最少的人
because that's when the opportunity for learning is greatest um he says as soon as he's the one in the room that like knows the most he's going to be learning the least. And that's right now at least where he's at in his career. He said that he's always trying to learn from other experts and constantly trying to find those opportunities, which I think I identify a lot with that sentiment like trying to learn from the experts around me. When I started at NVIDIA, the team that I formed there, there was an offer for us to move to a different part of the company where the part of the company that we were in and that we are in
因为那是学习机会最大的时候。他说，一旦他成为房间里知道最多的人，他学到的东西就会最少。至少目前他在职业生涯的这个阶段是这样。他说他一直在尝试向其他专家学习，并不断尝试寻找那些机会，我认为我非常认同这种情绪，就像尝试向我周围的专家学习一样。当我在NVIDIA开始工作时，我组建的团队，当时有一个机会让我们搬到公司的不同部门，我们所在的部门以及我们现在所在的
is the part of the company that develops the software that our team uses. And the offer was to move us to a part of the company where we would be surrounded by the people who use our software. And I said, no, I want us to stay in the part of the company that we're in right now because I want to be surrounded by the people who can answer my questions, not by the people who are going to ask me questions. Yeah, that's a good... There's another thing. Somebody told me something like this at C++ Now.
是公司开发我们团队所使用的软件的部分。而那个提议是让我们搬到公司的一个部门，在那里我们将被使用我们软件的人所包围。我说，不，我希望我们留在我们现在所在的部门，因为我想被那些能回答我问题的人包围，而不是被那些会问我问题的人包围。是的，那是一个很好的……还有另一件事。有人在C++ Now上告诉过我类似的事情。
And I think in my mind, I think it was Louis Dion, but I don't know that that was correct. It might've been that somebody said it about Louis, but it was something to the effect of somebody said that one of the signs of brilliance in a person is a willingness to rapidly change your stance or position with little hesitation when you come to believe that you're wrong. Essentially that, you know, that brilliant people are unafraid to, you know, change their minds to completely reverse their thinking when they have been convinced that their previous thinking was wrong. Yeah, this, oh man. So we're already over, I think, 40 minutes now,
我想在我的脑海里，我认为是Louis Dion说的，但我不知道那是否正确。可能是有人关于Louis说的，但大意是有人说，一个人才华的标志之一是愿意在认为自己错了时，毫不犹豫地迅速改变你的立场或观点。本质上，你知道，才华横溢的人不害怕，你知道，改变他们的想法，在他们被说服之前的想法是错误的时候，完全扭转他们的思维。是的，这个，哦天哪。所以我们已经超过了，我想，40分钟了，
but I have to tell this story. I hope Ivan doesn't mention me mentioning his name Yeah, this, oh man. So we're already over, I think 40 minutes now, but I have to tell this story. I hope, I hope Ivan doesn't mention me mentioning his name, but one of the smartest people I've ever met in my life is an individual. I'll just say his first name, Ivan. He, he, he was the chief actuary at the company that I started my career at. And I, I one time got the opportunity to talk to him over lunch for a couple hours and was asking him about how he got started in the industry. And he's got so many great stories. You know, one of, one of them is, is as an actuary, you have to write all these exams.
但我必须讲这个故事。我希望Ivan不要提到我提到他的名字。是的，这个，哦天哪。所以我们已经超过了，我想40分钟了，但我必须讲这个故事。我希望，我希望Ivan不要提到我提到他的名字，但我一生中见过的最聪明的人之一是一个人。我就只说他的名字，Ivan。他，他，他是我职业生涯开始那家公司的首席精算师。我，我曾经有机会在午餐时和他聊了几个小时，并问他关于他是如何进入这个行业的。他有很多很棒的故事。你知道，其中之一是，作为一名精算师，你必须参加所有这些考试。
And he had, um, come to Canada from Hong Kong. And so he rapidly started writing these tests because he wanted to get a job as a, you know, junior actuary. And upon interviewing at one of the companies, you know, at the time there was 10 exams, he had like one or two, and he didn't have any experience. And the person interviewing him said, you know, you should not, you should stop writing the exams, you're going to price yourself out of a job, like with zero experience in a bunch of exams, no one's going to want to hire you because they're going to have to pay you X and you're not going to be worth that. And so he said, oh, okay, my bad. So he stopped writing exams. Then he ended up getting a job at this company. And then another person said like, oh, like I see you haven't
他，嗯，从香港来到加拿大。所以他迅速开始参加这些考试，因为他想找一份工作，作为一名，你知道，初级精算师。在其中一家公司面试时，你知道，当时有10门考试，他只有一两门，而且他没有任何经验。面试他的人说，你知道，你不应该，你应该停止参加考试，你会因为没有经验却有一堆考试而让自己找不到工作，没有人会想雇佣你，因为他们必须付给你X，而你不值那个钱。所以他说，哦，好的，我的错。所以他停止了参加考试。然后他最终在那家公司找到了一份工作。然后另一个人说，哦，我看到你最近没有
written any exams recently. And he's like, yeah, you know, the interviewer told me not to. And he's like, what are you talking about? You should just get these exams done as fast as possible. And so then he went out and like wrote five in one sitting, which is like insane. Like people write one at a time, sometimes two. This guy signed up for five and passed them all. But the reason I tell you this whole story about Ivan is that in a meeting once, exactly what you said happened.
参加任何考试。他说，是的，你知道，面试官告诉我不要参加。他说，你在说什么？你应该尽快完成这些考试。所以他出去，一次参加了五门，这简直是疯了。就像人们一次参加一门，有时两门。这家伙报名参加了五门并且全部通过了。但我讲关于Ivan的整个故事的原因是，在一次会议上，发生了和你刚才说的一模一样的事情。
Some information changed and he had been going down some path of explanation and someone said oh no you've misunderstood and then in that in like a fraction of a second Ivan acknowledged that and then basically like turned 90 degrees and just said well if that's the case then everything I said before is false and we need to start talking about it like and I was just like I hadn't even registered what the like the new information that the person had said and ivan was already off like had had registered it you know baked it into his mental model and was off okay if that's the case uh like scratch everything i said before and now we're going
一些信息改变了，他一直沿着某种解释路径走，有人说哦不，你误解了，然后在不到一秒钟的时间里，Ivan承认了这一点，然后基本上就像转了90度，直接说，好吧，如果是这样的话，那么我之前说的一切都是错误的，我们需要开始讨论它，就像，我当时想，我甚至还没有注册那个人说的新信息，而Ivan已经离开了，就像已经注册了，你知道，把它融入了他的心理模型，并且离开了，好的，如果是这样的话，呃，就像划掉我之前说的一切，现在我们要
this direction i was just like holy smokes like the ability to do it like that fast um it wasn't even about the fact that he had like zero shame about misunderstanding it. It was the speed at which he did it. I was just like, oh my goodness, this guy's out of this world. And that's not to say that you always do that.
这个方向，我当时想，天哪，像那样快速做到这一点，这甚至不是关于他对于误解这件事毫无羞耻感的事实。而是他做到这一点时的速度。我当时想，哦天哪，这家伙简直不是这个世界的人。这并不是说你总是那样做。
I'm not saying that that means that you, that when presenting with new information, you always change your mind. What I'm talking about is exactly what you just said, that it's the capability.
我不是说这意味着你，当面对新信息时，你总是改变你的想法。我所说的是你刚才说的，这是一种能力。
It's the capability that in the right circumstances, when you hear the right thing that makes you rethink something, that you are able to just instantly change your worldview with like zero shame. And like, you know, there are times when you don't do that, when you're, you know, you really have a strong conviction about something and the new thing doesn't change your mind. And there's also times when it's more gradual where you also shouldn't be afraid to say one thing on a Friday and then think about it over a weekend. And then on Monday, after giving it some thought, change your mind. But that ability to like rapidly shift too, it's one of those signs of somebody
这是一种能力，在适当的情况下，当你听到正确的事情让你重新思考某事时，你能够瞬间改变你的世界观，而且毫无羞耻感。而且，你知道，有些时候你不会那样做，当你，你知道，你对某事有强烈的信念，而新事物并没有改变你的想法。还有些时候，它是更渐进的，你也应该不害怕在周五说一件事，然后在周末思考它。然后在周一，经过一些思考后，改变你的想法。但那种能够快速转变的能力，也是某人身上那些标志之一
that's really, really, really gifted. I've heard someone refer to it as flexibility of thought. It's that you have your thoughts and your opinions and whatever, your conviction and insert whatever it is, and then presented new information you're immediately able to digest that and like change your stance um and you're not just you know sticking to something because that's what you said last week um anyways we should we should start to wrap this up so we've sort of i do have a question for you though um what what is your learning love language? How do you learn best? I, well, so I'm not sure which way I learned the best. I know the way that I think though. And that's when I'm trying to learn something, I try to find the way I can think about it. And I
那是非常，非常，非常有天赋的。我听过有人称之为思维的灵活性。就是你有你的想法和观点，无论是什么，你的信念，插入任何东西，然后面对新信息，你能够立即消化它，并像改变你的立场，而且你不仅仅是，你知道，坚持某事，因为那是你上周说的。无论如何，我们应该，我们应该开始总结了。所以我们已经有点，我确实有一个问题要问你，不过，你的学习爱语是什么？你如何学习效果最好？我，嗯，所以我不太确定我哪种方式学习效果最好。但我知道我的思考方式。那就是当我试图学习某事时，我试图找到我能思考它的方式。而我
am a visual thinker. Um like right now, we started this in my meetup, we've started covering this category theory book. And so much of it is abstract, that like I'm having an immense, immensely difficult time like visualizing some of these things. When I think about algorithms, when I think about code, when I when I think about things, like everything is, is like the way that code flows, it's like a tree and every function is a node and if statements
是一个视觉思考者。嗯，就像现在，我们在我的聚会中开始了，我们已经开始涵盖这本范畴论的书。而且其中很多是抽象的，以至于我，在可视化其中一些事情方面遇到了巨大的，巨大的困难。当我思考算法时，当我思考代码时，当我思考事情时，就像一切都是，就像代码流动的路径，它就像一棵树，每个函数都是一个节点，如果语句
and other function calls and loops, they all sort of have this picture in my head so I can just walk through a code base and algorithms are very visual, like reverse, like you can visualize reversing something, rotating, you can visualize rotating two elements
和其他函数调用和循环，它们在我的脑海中都有这种画面，所以我可以走过一个代码库，算法是非常视觉化的，比如反转，就像你可以可视化反转某事，旋转，你可以可视化旋转两个元素
to the back of a list, sorting, like you can visualize a lot elements to the back of a list sorting like you can visualize a lot of algorithms and so i i think visually um so a lot of the times i really really like watching talks like for me the order is in terms of difficulty like reading is the hardest listening is the second hardest or the second easiest and then watching is the easiest like i usually tend to like try and read first get tired of that then listen to a podcast get tired of that and then watch
到列表的末尾，排序，就像你可以可视化很多元素到列表的末尾，排序，就像你可以可视化很多算法，所以我，我进行视觉思考，所以很多时候我真的，真的喜欢看演讲，对我来说，顺序是就难度而言，阅读是最难的，听是第二难的，或者第二容易的，然后看是最容易的，所以我通常倾向于尝试先阅读，厌倦了那个，然后听播客，厌倦了那个，然后看
because like watching a lecture for me is like fun and a lot of the times if you have a great person that is giving the lecture or a great conference talk you know not all of them are amazing but every once in a while you'll just click with the person that's giving the talk and they'll have some visual or like they'll be walking you through the code and then things will click immediately so yeah your question was like how do i learn i basically just try and like do the firehose method of just like consuming everything and anything because i'm also the kind of person that like sometimes i need to hear something like four or five times in slightly different ways for it to register a couple different times now
因为对我来说，看讲座就像很有趣，而且很多时候，如果你有一个很棒的人在做讲座，或者一个很棒的会议演讲，你知道，并不是所有的都很棒，但偶尔你会和做演讲的人产生共鸣，他们会有一些视觉效果，或者他们会带你浏览代码，然后事情会立即点击。所以是的，你的问题是，我如何学习，我基本上只是尝试，就像使用消防水管方法，就像消费一切和任何东西，因为我也是那种人，有时我需要听四五次，以稍微不同的方式，它才能注册，几次不同的时间现在
i've pointed out that i learned about immediately invoked lambdas from ben dean's talk but i had actually seen them in a phil nash talk like three years earlier but i just my mind wasn't like ready to learn that thing anyway so i'm not sure that answers your question but i think it answers it so the question is or the the way to wrap this up, though, is how do we bundle all these different things that you've said? So, you know, finding a mentor, finding what you really want to do, not underestimating how much you can get done or accomplish. I would call the episode, like, finding your way.
我指出我从Ben Dean的演讲中了解了立即调用的lambda，但我实际上在三年前的Phil Nash的演讲中见过它们，但我只是我的头脑还没有准备好学习那个东西。无论如何，我不确定这是否回答了你的问题，但我认为它回答了。所以问题是，或者总结这一点的方式是，我们如何将你所说的所有这些不同的事情捆绑在一起？所以，你知道，找到一个导师，找到你真正想做的事情，不要低估你能完成或实现多少。我会把这一集命名为，比如，找到你的路。
Thanks for listening, and we hope you have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听，希望你度过愉快的一天。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。